[Music]
on its Wednesday night Canadians digging
themselves deeper into debt buying a
house on a normal income is pretty much
impossible the potential Solutions and
the consequences for the Next Generation
big cutbacks at Bell Media it is a shame
the job losses and the crushing blow to
Canadian journalism
to their Roots we're very advanced in
The Sciences of plant knowledge the
traditional Garden in Winnipeg
nourishing bodies and souls
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us there is a
fresh warning tonight to keep an eye on
your household debt new numbers show it
is on the rise again in Canada the ratio
of household debt to disposable income
Rose to nearly 185 percent in the first
quarter of this year and that means for
every dollar of disposable income the
average Canadian household now owes
about a dollar 85 pile on Rising
interest rates and you can see where
this is going in the U.S the Federal
Reserve did pause its interest rate
hikes today but Warren more are coming
and we could see the same here in Canada
Eric Sorensen on the impact this is
having on Canadians already struggling
to pay their bills
there are the big banks that do lending
and nowadays small lenders like Bob and
Sheila Spears the so-called Bank of mom
and dad helping their daughter and their
grandchild Grady to buy a home the point
is they can't do what we did without
external help just buying a house on a
normal income is pretty much impossible
our parents could do it but they sure
couldn't do it today how many Canadians
are doing it is by taking on more debt
household debt is on the rise again as a
proportion of household disposable
income up to almost 185 percent close to
twice as much debt for every dollar of
disposable income the level of house
prices is really high the amount of that
that has to be taken on is enormous and
so people are going to have to spend
many years
saving in order to get that down payment
higher interest rates are discouraging
many potential first-time home buyers
from taking out mortgages and the trend
shows that the loan amount for
first-time mortgages is down while the
monthly payment continue to go up in
short when it comes to mortgages for
first-time home buyers you're paying
more for Less any savings that you've
gotten on the sticker price of the home
has been more than made up for uh by by
those higher interest payments if
interest rates keep going up it just
gets harder and harder to get into this
Market higher mortgages will force many
to cut other spending or even downsize
their homes for others it could mean a
30-year mortgage won't be long enough
what's needed says The Economist with
Canada mortgage and housing is more
housing a lot more housing Supply we
need more stuff built in order to try
and start downward pressure on these
house prices but building enough new
housing won't happen overnight the
younger people that it gets saddled with
our ridiculous debt Bob Spears says
governments and Banks should have seen
this coming and now young people are
paying for it now the first generation
that's been completely shut out of that
because of interest rates and not
managing the process properly Eric
Sorensen Global News to throttle
Canada's news media landscape shrank
again today Bell Media announced
sweeping layoffs cutting 1300 jobs
closing radio stations laying off some
prominent journalists and shutting ctv's
only remaining overseas news Bureau Bell
says it can't afford to keep operating
the way it was Toria Israel on the cuts
the reaction and what these repeated
cutbacks mean for journalism
well Canada the parent company of CTV
News is cutting 1300 jobs CTV News is
reporting on itself now with a smaller
team behind and in front of the camera
the six percent cut at Bell Media its
parent company Bell Media is shedding
hundreds of positions and letting go of
some of Canada's best-known journalists
so far they say senior reporters in the
Ottawa Bureau have been laid off nearly
all CTV foreign correspondents are gone
and its presence in Washington reduced
CTV has some really experienced
hard-working talented journalists who
Canadians have come to rely on Bell
Media is also scaling back local news
closing six radio stations and selling
three others I was blindsided the
layoffs came after a high profile exit
last summer when former CTV National
anchor Lisa leflam was abruptly ousted
the company says it can't afford its
current operations after a drop in
viewers and profits in an open letter
the president of Bell Canada writes the
company expects to lose more than 250
million dollars in Legacy phone revenues
per year while its news operations incur
40 million dollars in annual operating
losses the media segment has been
underperforming and so I think that
we're going to see more moves that are
reflective the Liberals tabled Bill c-18
to try to level the playing field
requiring Tech giants like Facebook and
Google to pay news organizations for
repurposing their content most of the
advertising is going to a few big
players like Facebook and and Google
that bill is still before the Senate but
with the news landscape shrinking media
experts warn Canadian democracy is in
danger you're missing the accountability
and you're missing just a sense of the
things you need to know if you want to
be an Engaged citizen while Bell Canada
says its revenue and news was down it
made almost 790 million dollars in the
last quarter calling it a solid start to
the year
Global News Ottawa
there are calls for Canada's Public
Safety minister to resign over the way
he and his office handled information
about the transfer of convicted serial
killer Paul Bernardo to a medium
security prison
prime minister is someone going to lose
their job over Paul bernardo's transfer
introducing the Republicans
it's now emerged mendocino's office New
for months that Bernardo would be moved
but when it happened the minister said
he was shocked by the information
Bernardo was convicted in 1995 a first
degree murder in the deaths of Christian
French and Leslie Mahaffey they were
kidnapped raped and tortured and the
victim's families want Bernardo back in
maximum security David Aiken on how the
whole thing has become a political issue
the public safety Minister says he was
surprised to learn of Paul bernardo's
move I formed on May 30th the day after
Paul Bernardo was physically transferred
to a medium security institution but the
correctional service of Canada now says
it warned mendicino's political staff in
email sent March 2nd and again on May
the 25th that Bernardo was about to be
moved from the maximum security facility
near Kingston Ontario to a medium
security prison in Lama Casa Quebec the
opposition says that having been warned
Mendocino should have stepped in and
stopped the transfer he has the power
now to designate Mass murderers all to
go into maximum security prisons he
could have done that weeks ago if the
minister can't keep his house in order
how is he going to keep the country safe
when will the minister stop waiting
beside a fax machine and start checking
his emails for these serious updates
Corrections Canada officials say though
that under Canadian law the decision to
transfer prisoners is up to prison
officials not politicians that
technicality mattered to the minister
the leader of the Conservative Party of
Canada lays out a prescription for
political interference which foreshadows
what Canadians would get with a
conservative government but it did not
matter to the opposition leader so will
he do the only honorable thing that is
left for him to do and resign the
families of bernardo's victims are less
concerned with the politics and more
concerned that Bernardo B returned to
maximum security it's very very uh
disturbing for them no just I'm sorry
that's an understatement I mean they're
actually devastated by this this is this
is actually crushing on them to them
um when something like this occurs it
takes them back to day one Mr Marco
Mendicino said he spoke Wednesday
morning to Tim Danson and he has since
instructed the head of Correctional
Services Canada to review bernardo's
transfer but there is no timeline right
now as to when that review will be
complete Donna okay David Aiken in
Ottawa thanks Canada will need more
resources to fight wildfires in the
years ahead that was the message from
the Prime Minister today who was in
Quebec being briefed on the fire
situation prime minister Trudeau says
Canada will count on other countries to
send help just as countries depend on
Canadian firefighters
extreme weather events are going to
become more and more frequent over the
coming years with climate change and
that means we're going to have to
continue learning continue looking at
how to prepare for the coming years how
to work even better together
of the 455s burning in Canada now about
130 are in Quebec and 35 of those are
out of control rain is in the forecast
over the next few days but fire
officials warn it may not be enough to
make a difference before temperatures
Rise Again by the end of the week in
Ukraine Russia has Unleashed another
deadly round of overnight missile
attacks
this is the moment a woman was pulled
from the rubble in Ukraine after a
missile strike leveled multiple homes in
the Donetsk region three people are
known to have died and further south in
the Black Sea port of Odessa the search
is on for survivors after a cluster of
strikes there left at least three people
dead
Ukraine says it's made further advances
in its counter-offensive the Russian
President Vladimir Putin denied that
during a rare extended interview he did
with more than a dozen journalists in
Moscow today and a close Ally of Putin
the president of Belarus says his
country has started taking delivery of
Russian tactical nuclear weapons Redmond
Shannon reports
speaking with Russian State media
Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenka said some of the expected
delivery of tactical nuclear weapons has
already arrived from Russia
we have missiles and bombs that we have
received from Russia that are three
times more powerful than those dropped
in Hiroshima and Nagasaki up to a
million people would die immediately if
God forbid this weapon were used Russian
troops have already used Belarus as a
staging ground for the full-scale
invasion of Ukraine this movement of
tactical nuclear weapons was first
announced Wednesday in March and it
would Mark the first time that Annie
have left Russia in this way since the
end of the Soviet Union exiled
Belarusian opposition leaders fiatlana
tikanovski has said it creates a serious
threat to Regional security and sets us
on a dangerous path for nuclear
escalation so far we haven't seen any
changes in their posture that requires
any changes in our milk depository Putin
argues this is no different than the U.S
stationing around 100 of its nuclear
bombs in five NATO countries of course
the difference we have to make is that
Russia is at War and NATO is not nuclear
weapons can be defined as strategic
fired at long-range targets or tactical
designed for Battlefield use but as
lukashenka suggested they have no limit
in size Russia is using nuclear weapons
again without deploying them in a
military sense but using them as as
means of political coercion to force
now calls the union state in February
Russia suspended the new start treaty
that places limits on strategic nuclear
warheads Putin says the tactical weapons
will be deployed and ready soon after
the Belarus storage facility is
completed in early July Redmond Channel
and Global News London
a first for Canada to combat toxic drug
use coming up the province that will
provide Universal coverage for opioid
treatments plus what parents say
happened to their daughter at a school
track and field event NBC
BC's government says it will provide
Universal coverage for opioid treatment
such as methadone becoming the first
Province to do so BC's Ministry of
mental health and addiction says the
coverage is now in effect for all
residents with an active Medical
Services plan it aims to remove the cost
barriers for people who are seeking
medication instead of illicit opioids
and hopes to help people stabilize their
lives and prevent deaths there have been
more than 11 000 toxic drug-related
deaths since BC declared a public health
emergency in 2016. there was outrage in
Kelowna after a young girl competing at
a school track meet apparently became
the target of a transphobic tirade the
family of the nine-year-olds has a
couple harassed the girl even demanding
proof of her gender while hurling
insults at her parents BC's Premier says
that kind of hate is not acceptable or
welcome in British Columbia nithu
garchod what happened and the reaction
this Spring Track Meet in Kelowna BC
took an unexpected and horrible turn
when the gender of a nine-year-old girl
taking part in a shot put event was
questioned in an anti-trans attack
according to her mother who watched it
all unfold all of a sudden there was
this yelling of
um
well I didn't hear what Heidi heard at
first but then get that boy off the
field sort of thing
and then it took a minute to realize
that they were talking about our
daughter Carrie Starr says her daughter
whose identity is being protected always
had long hair and recently decided to
cut it shorter because it made playing
sports easier our daughter was crying
inconsolably because he's just
continuing to Badger her but he wouldn't
let it go this gentleman wouldn't let it
go
kept badgering and yelling demanding
certification of her being female the
school district superintendent told
Global News its own investigation found
a couple was being belligerent and
intimidating to the point where the
sporting event had to be moved to a
different location and the couple who
was there to support a grandchild from
another school district didn't leave as
directed The offenders here are going to
be banned from all future
school events and school properties
because they're clearly not safe around
children our human rights laws are very
clear you can't discriminate on the
basis of gender identity or gender
expression Dr Elizabeth seawick heads a
research center focused on stigma and
youth trans and non-binary young people
are less likely to participate in sports
half as likely girls
of any background are also less likely
to stay in sports
she says misinformation about trans
issues is fueling bigotry at a growing
rate a protest in Ottawa Friday
organized by a group against what they
call gender ideology was met with
hundreds of counter protesters
local police say they're investigating
the incident but not as a hate crime all
the girls in that event were
flabbergasted like shocked as support
continues to pour in for the girl after
an incident the family says has left
many reeling Global News Vancouver
Donald Trump's Defiance ahead why his
arraignment hasn't slowed his
presidential campaign
[Music]
Donald Trump spent his 77th birthday
today facing Federal criminal charges
and bracing for further legal Bombshells
set to come his way he is not treating
it as a setback though on the contrary
he is fundraising on the back of it and
is still considered the front runner to
be the Republican party's Presidential
nominee Jackson prosco reports
there was no sign of a man humbled by
his day in court I had every right to
have these documents as Donald Trump
spoke to Big Money donors in New Jersey
he played his Greatest Hits victimhood
and Vengeance I will appoint a real
special prosecutor
corrupt president of the history of the
United States of America Joe Biden
but its special counsel Jack Smith's
investigation into Trump that has made
history with its dozens of criminal
charges Trump calls it a Witch Hunt the
Attorney General says otherwise it
underscores
the Justice Department's commitment
to oath Independence and accountability
this is no simple brush with the law
Trump is alleged to have hoarded
documents outlining the nation's most
closely guarded secrets you have Trump
being recorded making Admissions and
also his own posts on social media where
he says I knew these documents were
classified in Florida prosecutors have
promised a swift trial historically
Trump's legal strategy has been to delay
and run out the clock which would mean
running up against the 2024 election
Trump may win the primary yet Trump has
a unique ability to capitalize on his
troubles he fundraised over 2 million
dollars in the hours following his court
appearance the broader public is looking
at this more uh critically than than
Republicans are and that's essentially
where the election is going to be
defined the judicial system is far from
done with the former president thank you
whether Americans view him as damaged
goods or a defiant savior May well be
decided in the court of public opinion
Trump still is the possibility of being
indicted in Georgia over alleged
election interference there we've
learned that police from the Atlanta
area were in Miami to witness Trump's
arraignment as part of their own
security preparations
Donna okay Jackson prosco in Miami thank
you
natural nourishment next the indigenous
gardening Traditions helping communities
eat healthier
at pride and cultural awareness extends
to all kinds of passions including
gardening growing food can be incredibly
rewarding and for indigenous people
doing it using their traditional
knowledge is nourishing bodies and souls
Melissa ridgeen reports
this might look like a tangle of weeds
but soon an inner city Community will be
fed from what's growing here we don't do
rose we don't do we intersperse so
companion planting is very important
First Nations have always grown certain
plants together to nourish and protect
each other like this group The Three
Sisters corn to support beans that will
grow up its stock beans will provide
shade to the sunshine squash and squash
will cover the ground keeping weeds away
and they'll be helped by their sister
tobacco a natural herbicide growing
among them when Europeans came over they
did not recognize our method of growing
and because of that they were then able
to use the doctrine of Discovery to take
the land from the people I do a more
natural method of growing there's a
modern word that they use which is
permaculture Logan says it's a holistic
way of growing that typically yields
More Produce with less work just
misunderstandings
that that indigenous people were
primitive
when in fact we're very Advanced very
advanced in The Sciences of plant
knowledge walking the Garden Path with
knowledge of their ancestors nourishes
their Spirit as does sharing it with
others like Louise May who operates an
organic farm using Logan's teachings the
sisters planting as I have learned it is
a super economical really smart kind of
way to combine plants and to work with
this prairie ecosystem so it's obvious
that it took hundreds of years if not
more to develop this and it still
remains to this day a very important way
to farm our land back at the inner city
community garden the fruits and
vegetables of Logan's labor will feed
others who work here Sweat Equity of ten
dollars an hour buys additional produce
from a co-op with local farmers a
partnership that should bloom in every
Community they say especially at a time
when food costs can make eating healthy
difficult Melissa Ridge in Global News
Winnipeg
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the world's largest
tomahawk in the town of Cut Knife
Saskatchewan we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you